Artificial intelligence is taking over the
world. We can see in AI art, some pretty cool
AI portraits, in chat bots, and tons more.
Now you might think chatbots suck though
right? Wrong. There are already AI tools like
OpenAI's ChatGPT that can generate short essays,
do research, give directions, solve math
problems, write high level coding sequences,
and generate cooking instructions based on certain
prompts. They can even write entire movie scripts.
Now I'm not saying that these scripts are
Oscar-worthy screenplays or anything, but
they could definitely get there within the next
few years. Before we dive into this though, I just
want to say that I'm not here to scaremonger or
say that AI is going to completely take over the
movie industry overnight or even take away your
job, but it's definitely worth considering how AI
could potentially change the way we live our lives
and how we make movies in the future. So to see
just how far away we are from AI taking over the
world, I decided to test it out. Write a title and
script for a movie that's a cross between Shrek
and Back to the Future. Title: Shrek to the Future
they gathered around Thanos who lay defeated
at their feet Thor approached the villain
Thanos for your crimes against the Universe
I sentence you to a fate worse than death
you'll be forced to watch all of the
Real Housewives franchises back to back
advancing at an alarming rate it's already being
utilized in the film industry for tasks such as
special effects and post-production work as AI
becomes more sophisticated and widely adopted
there is a terrifying possibility that it could
take on more complex tasks and decision making
within the industry such as writing scripts
or directing movies the Cutthroat and cause
sensitive nature of the film industry could also
Drive the adoption of AI leading to an uncertain
future for human professionals we should
brace ourselves for the possibility that
AI could eventually become a central player in
the production process of our beloved movies the
thought of this is really terrifying don't believe
me well that entire paragraph was just written by
AI so we're basically already there okay so
chat GPT can write but what about the actual
production of movies could AI eventually take over
tasks like directing editing and even acting it's
definitely possible we've already seen AI being
used to generate visual effects and create entire
music scores and AI can create lifelike human
profiles that read out scripts so I don't think
we're too far away from AI Bots being developed
that can rival young directors or professional
video editors so what does all this mean for the
future of the movie industry it's hard to say for
certain but it's definitely worth considering how
AI could change the way we make movies it could
lead to more efficient and cost-effective movie
production but it could also potentially lead to
the displacement of human workers and the end of
the movie industry as we know it I think tools
like chat GPT are just that tools we shouldn't
rely on them to do our jobs for us but use them to
get the ball rolling or to solve simpler problems
when my parents were in school they faced the
rise of the pocket calculator that could do math
for you then I think of AI like a calculator but
instead of doing exponents and reciprocals they
can come up with video titles or find an issue and
some code my fear is that Hollywood will get lazy
and rely too heavily on AI platforms like chat GPT
surrendering the human element of filmmaking to
a life less robot and I really hope that doesn't
happen don't forget to like And subscribe
bye [Music] [Applause] [Music] [Applause]